the number one job of any brand is to  get people to fall in love with it  um this announcement today from V  friends our project is a big deal it's a  big deal it's just common sense  Common Sense cow it's common sense to  get as many people to fall in love with  the brand as possible getting these  collectible figurines and plush into all  the Toys R Us's inside of Macy's stores  around the country in the U.S is a big  big deal Andy it's a big deal hey look  at Andrews it's a big deal free shipping  if you buy two or more all right relaxes  it's a green screen this is to educate  what you're supposed to do when you  build a brand which is get people to  fall in love and that means multiple  executions not just nfts not just  collectible plush and figurines but  cartoons and movies and books and  sneakers and it's all coming it's all  coming  Link in my profile to join the Discord